Ultra stinks let's hear it question what
happens when the irresistible force
meets the immovable object if you want
to build ultimate power and strength and
there may be one form of exercise that's
better than any other isometric training
and not to just isometric training but
isometric training used it the way I'm
about to explain if you watch this
channel before then you might know a
little bit about muscle fiber
recruitment so whenever we engage in any
exercise we need to recruit muscle fiber
in order to make that movement so if we
throw a punch if we lift a weight then
we're using the muscle fibers in our
muscles and they're working as the kind
of primary drivers of that exercise they
give us the force and they allow us to
do whatever it is we're trying to do
lots of fiber recruitment refers to how
many of those muscle fibers we can use
in one go and the surprising thing is
that most of us have a lot of dormant
untapped potential because we can only
use about 30% up to 50% for the very
most elite athletes of our muscle fiber
in one go and this is because we don't
want to fatigue ourselves completely we
don't injure ourselves so our central
nervous system has a kind of suppressant
effect to prevent us from using 100% of
our strength at once but certain types
of situation can allow us to tap into
this strength hysterical strength is
when a mother sees her child trapped
underneath a car and she's able to call
upon superhuman power to lift the car
off the child you hear stories about
things like this happening we don't know
how accurate those stories are but it's
certainly likely that there's some truth
behind the tales and what's probably
going on here is that a sudden release
of adrenaline and other
neurotransmitters and hormones is
allowing our body to retrieve this kind
of untapped strength this hidden
potential because we're in a dire need
for it another example of just how
strong we are without even realizing it
is what happens when we get electrocuted
if you've ever seen on TV or in a
cartoon someone get electrocuted though
is thrown across the room and the
assumption you might think is that it's
some kind of explosion blowing them
backwards but actually it's nothing like
that the reason they get thrown across
the room is because there
are all contracting at once because the
current is causing them to do that and
that means that just that strength alone
is enough to throw them across the room
just tensing the muscles in their legs
and their abs is throwing them across
the room this way if you could tap into
100 percent of your strength you'd be
able to do that at will and using a form
of training called overcoming isometrics
it may be possible to tap into this
dormant strength this is because we're
reducing the suppressant effect of our
central nervous system so in overcoming
isometrics what we're doing is with
pushing or pulling against an immovable
object so in a typical exercise you lift
something that's heavy and you can only
just move it 10 or 12 times for your
curls but in an overcoming isometric
exercise you're moving something or
trying to move something that just won't
budge so you're stuck in just one
position it's isometric meaning it's
static and you're not going anywhere
you're using maximal contraction but
with no range of motion the other form
of isometric exercise is called yielding
isometric that's where you're holding
something in position purposefully that
you could curl or you could press
whatever but you're just holding it in
that one position until you give out and
your arms give way and you lower the
weight but it's overcoming isometric
what we're looking at here this is the
kind that you use to build pure strength
and the reason for this is basically
that you're using a maximal contraction
for the longest time possible
so if you want to increase your strength
normally you'd use some kind of power
lifting a weight lifting technique and
that would usually involve lifting a
weight that's close to your one rep max
once twice or three times and because
it's so close to your one rep max you're
calling on as much strength as possible
and your body adapts to give you more
strength but even when you're lifting a
one rep max you're still only maximally
contracting the muscle for a brief
period so say you were to curl a one rep
max this is not a great example but it
it's useful to demonstrate what some sat
down so what was happen is you would be
using a hundred turn your strength but
only for a brief second because you've
got momentum
you've got gravity and you're only using
the maximum strength at the point where
you struggle most on the other hand with
a static contraction exercise you're
pulling or pushing against something and
using a hundred percent of your effort
and because you're staying in that one
position you will continue to use a
hundred percent
because there's no fear of dropping the
weight on yourself or injuring yourself
it's relatively safe to do this it's no
coincidence that Dennis Rogers who many
people think is the strongest man alive
pound for pound uses this form of
training he will use overcoming
isometrics by bending steel and pushing
against things that won't move and in an
episode of Stan Lee's superhumans they
observed his muscle fibers at work and
found that he was able to recruit a
higher percentage of muscle fiber than
your average Joe and this could be
attributed to genetics but it's also
likely that some of it is down to using
overcoming isometrics which I say is
what a lot of old-time strongmen would
do even Bruce Lee we can attribute a lot
of his incredible power to overcoming
isometrics this is a form of training we
know that he used quite different from a
lot of other people and then he someone
else who's got all these impressive
feats we don't know if they're real or
not but he's been said to be able to
punch his little finger through a can of
coca-cola hold a barbell out 40
kilograms for a long period of time
do those one-finger push-ups so
regardless of whether that specifically
is true point is there's no denying that
overcoming isometrics is fantastic for
building a kind of strength that you
might not already have if you're not
using this form of training both from
the magnitude of the EMG signal and from
the fact that this entire area the
screen is whited out he's able to
activate a lot of motor units a lot of
muscle fibers there are certainly other
people walking around
that have muscles that are just as big
as yours however for some reason you're
able to activate more of those muscle
fibers once again this is said specific
adaptations to impose demands I've said
it a lot of times but if you want to
train for anything in particular you
have to do that thing and in in the case
of overcoming isometrics you're trying
to recruit more strength than you have
access to so that's sending a very clear
signal to your body that it needs dapped
and give you more strength so it only
follows that this would be such an
effective way to build pure power the
first thing that you see is that we're
gonna have to turn the gain down on the
EMG machine he's off the charts we had
the machine set up for most of the
general population and athletes that we
test in this lab and obviously he's not
the same so what I want to do in this
video is a recap on that because I have
gone over it before but I've got a lot
of new subscribers now but also talk
about what the best way to get the best
results from that kind of training is
and the first thing I want to go over is
just how long to hold that maximal
contraction for and according to
research if it's strength and power
you're interested in then you should be
holding these positions for about 6
seconds so if you're pushing against the
wall you're going to hold that for 6
seconds and that's one repetition you
don't want to do it for too long because
you'll fatigue your central nervous
system and who don't do it long enough
then it's not enough of a challenge to
be that much different from any other
form of exercise so 6 seconds seems to
be the golden number but I'm sure you
can vary it a little the other thing you
might be wondering is whether it can
truly build strength through a full
range of motion or whether it will only
build strength in that one position well
it turns out that most of the strength
gains will be at that joint angle
however you will get around ten to
thirty percent the results vary
depending on who you read but 10 to 30
percent of overspill into other joint
angles so in other words if you train
this position then you might get some
benefit here and some benefit here but
this position is going to remain
unaffected and that means that in order
to get the best results from overcoming
isometrics you really want to train in
at least three positions three different
joint angles so you might do the
beginning of the movement hold it around
here just where it starts to get hard
the middle of the movement where
you're normally doing the kind of
maximum contraction and then the top of
the movement
just before you would start to lower it
and you'd hold each one for six seconds
I would recommend even breaking that
down further into four just to make sure
you're completely covering the full
range of motion of course there are
other utilities for overcoming
isometrics where you might for instance
use it to train a specific stumbling
point a specific failure point in one
exercise so say you're doing bench press
and you find that you always fail sort
of here that's where it becomes most
difficult as you're reaching your
failure point well then you might do
some isometric overcoming isometrics
here just to build up that extra bit of
strength at the point where you usually
fail to help yourself all the way
through another way you can use
overcoming isometrics which won't
involve going through each different
joint angle is to focus on just the
starting strength just the beginning of
the movement and this way you can use
something that's called explosive
isometrics or ballistic isometrics and
here you're not moving but you're doing
so explosively which might sound a lot
like a contradiction in terms but if you
imagine it so you're pushing against
your own hands this is an example then
instead of just pushing it I'm gonna
start off by immediately trying to
contract as much of the muscle as
possible to recruit as much of the
muscle as quickly as possible as I can
as though I'm exploding into that full
contraction you can also do that at
different joint angles but particularly
for the start of the movement for the
starting strength that would be very
useful for say a runner trying to get
the most explosive start off the box or
for someone throwing punches to try and
get the fastest delivery etc and in
terms of how many sets and repetitions
you should do I couldn't find any
concrete advice I can only share what
I've been doing and I say because this
is essentially equivalent to doing one
rep max which you wouldn't normally do
for too many sets and reps I say do the
same here and maybe train each angle
three to six times at most and you don't
want to over fatigue yourself but it is
a bit safer than doing one rep max so in
total if you go through three positions
and you're doing three to six different
reps at each of those angles that's
still quite a lot of work and it should
do just fine you should use a becoming
isometrics at the start of your workouts
before you get fatigued and that
you can recruit the most strength and
get the best strength of benefits if you
do reverse pyramid training where you
start with your heaviest weight and then
go down which is the way I like to train
then you can think of your overcoming
isometrics as being heavier than your
one rep max so you can start with
overcoming isometrics and then drop down
to a really heavy repetition and down
and down if you're wondering whether or
not this form of training is useful for
building muscle mass then unfortunately
not really it will increase your
strength and power through increasing
your muscle fiber recruitment or maybe
build muscle density and tonus but it
won't swell your muscles or increase
your muscle endurance it's not great for
body building style training it will
build your strength and having more
strength is great for building mass in
other ways and like I say this can go
great at the start of some kind of
massive drop set so there's ways you can
bind it together if you wanted to use
isometrics for building muscle mass they
need to want to use yielding isometrics
where you're holding a weight that you
could curl or press but you're just
going to hold it in position until you
fail and you'd want to do that for
longer durations 20 to 60 seconds and
this will pull the blood and build-up
the metabolites which provide the
stimulus for growth I'm gonna talk more
about that in future I might also talk
about stretched isometric so let me know
in the comments down below if you'd like
to hear more on that topic but finally
now I just want to go over how you would
actually implement some of these ideas
because obviously overcoming isometrics
is not something that you normally do
and there aren't tons of tools in the
gym or at your local fitness store that
can help you to do it you've got to get
a little bit creative so one way to do
it obviously is to go on to a resistance
machine and to set it too high so you
can't push it or pull it this works in
an extent that it's hard to change the
angle so slightly better still is to
just find some that doesn't move you can
train like the Indian wrestler Gama and
push or pull against a tree or if you
don't have a tree nearby you can use
your own wall or a door frame and in
order to change the angle that you're
training at you need to change your
position so I've been looking at how you
could use at the top of a door frame for
overhead presses I've seen a lot of
people recommend that but they don't
seem to think about the fact that they
need to train at different angles so the
way you might get around that is to
stand on a chair and then bend your legs
to different degrees whilst pushing
against
sealing of your doorframe obviously
anything that you can hold you can try
and pull apart or bend or squish and
this is how a lot of old-time strong men
trained this is how a lot of current
strong men build their strength it's
great for grip
training and just that kind of crushing
strength which is so useful in a range
of different situations so one example
of this might be to find an iron bar and
try and bend it or so I've seen people
roll up frying pans which is insane or
use a rope and pull it or tear a phone
book in half this kind of thing those
are examples of overcoming isometrics
where you're using a hundred percent of
your strength eventually might give out
but until then you're trying to recruit
all of that muscle fiber another option
is to use something called self
resistance and this simply means you're
using your own body to provide the
resistance and a simple example is this
kind of chest press move which is
similar to a PEC fly I'm squeezing my
arms together and if I want to change
the angle what I need to do is change
the lever arm which I can do by moving
my arms outward slightly another example
is to resist yourself whilst trying to
curl and a great one I find is to resist
yourself whilst trying to do a sit-up so
I put my forearms on my knees like so
and I try and push my body downwards
fold it in half making sure to use my
abs specifically and again I can change
the angle just by bending my arms to
provide the resistance a different point
and one thing that's great with using a
wall or tree whether using your own body
is that you can change the angle in a
kind of slow way which means for
instance I can push against my arms like
this and then just allow myself to move
ever so slightly as I go so I can
actually train through a slightly larger
range of motion that way but how you
work that into your sets and reps is up
to you remember the aim here is not to
fatigue yourself this is a very
intensive form of training another great
thing about these self resistance
exercises that you can do them anywhere
and no one even has to know so if you're
in a conversation it's pretty boring you
can just secretly be training your abs
and you know interesting really
interesting they'll just think that
you've got constipation or something
their big deal I've actually built a
whole load of different contraptions
that I use for
overcoming isometrics if you're a fan of
this channel and you've been watching
for a long time then you might remember
my greatest invention the rope attached
to a stick
so here I've attached a rope to a stick
a metal stick it's actually used to be a
pull-up bar so it's perfect because it
won't Bend it's designed to take a lot
of weight you can stand on the pull-up
bar and try and curl or row the weight
the the rope or vice versa you can hold
to the bar and you can stand on the rope
and you can do all kinds of different
things with that and it provides the
kind of resistance what bruce lee did
was he had a chain attached to a piece
of metal and he would try and curl or
press that metal against the chain but a
rope is much cheaper much more practical
if you stand on it wear shoe so you
don't hurt your feet or slippers if
you're me and you're lazy then you can
provide all the resistance you need like
I say you can get a rope from Amazon or
something and mine the thing cost five
quid so this is a rope that are a really
useful piece of training equipment you
can also just try and tear them you can
hold them at different lengths to change
the angle they're fantastic so invest in
a rope if you want a really cheap and
easy piece of training equipment so hope
you found this video useful interesting
guys if you did then please leave a like
please subscribe hit the bell button if
you'd like to get notifications if you
want to help this channel and it's been
growing fast thanks to all of you guys
so you're already helping a great deal
but if you want to help more and see
more like this then one of the best
things you can do for me actually is to
follow me on social media I'd love to
see you over on Instagram and Twitter
and also Facebook week and hear about my
latest videos and my other escapades
also share this video on reddit if you
wouldn't mind that helps a massive
amount likewise if you're a member of
any forums etc then just sharing it
around helped so much and I really
appreciate that so like I say hope you
found this useful let me know in the
comments what you think if there's any
forms of overcoming isometrics that I
missed out or the you thought of
yourself would love to hear them and
I'll see you next time where I'll be
talking about something related to this
or mainly brain training or productivity
or parkour martial arts or working
online whoo neighs so if that sounds
good
then stay tuned and I'll see you next
time thanks for watching and bye for now